good morning so as you can see by the
screen here 32 not by however two things
did happen my art shrinks old and my
gilded plate like set has bought so I
don't know if I'm gonna make money off
of this I don't know if maybe it dropped
overnight or what happened hopefully I
didn't drop as you can see 5.1 bills the
estimated price will make a little bit
of money off of it hopefully there we go
so just got back from work and as you
can see the gilded plates set their
plate like set has sold for 5.9 mil I
also put in a really low ball offer for
snapdragon seeds I'm not getting 100 and
I do think I'm about to take a nap
however I you know I checked out the
merchant master once is actually not bad
um they don't buy and sell too often
however I am just going to throw these
back on in um probably won't merge them
much in the future both of the master
ones have sold so I've barely made any
profit off of that but I finally got him
to sell realize it's not that great of
an item it's something that you would
think would be really good because it's
very it's not very like thought of I
wouldn't say among mergers at least it
it really comes to my mind but
apparently someone always almost always
has it unlocked so find some margins on
the serpentine Helms about 32 K so if
these all buy and sell which they've all
bought none of them have sold I would
make about 210 K a little bit of time
has passed and all of the serpentine
Helms have sold so we're now up to you
twenty four point seven overnight I'm
Anna and she'll buy two gilded sets for
5.02 five mill I don't know if they'll
make that much money off of them maybe
like a hundred K each but I'm a little
bit nonetheless well interestingly
enough all of my given plate leg sets
have bought however none of sold so
after after got done with work we ended
up selling all these thankfully so now
we're now at 24 point Oh almost 25
minutes so after the SMAP dragon seeds
have both I did this overnight I'm just
following my other account apparently
they are selling for folks forty-nine
five hundred so we're gonna put that in
for this and as you can see nine point
nine mill initially bought it for nine
point six six so a good 240 K profit so
something a little interesting just
happened I checked out the treasonous
rings price
as you can see one five nine one what's
the price that I was gonna sell them or
buy the mat and put an offer in the
insta watt and I got a hundred K for
each ring bag so I bought these at one
point for nine to both ended up insta
buying another three as you can see for
the same price I don't know what that's
all about
I don't know how that happened but
pretty much six mil plus that so we're
looking at about ten point four mil ish
for the total price to buy all of them
and I'm selling them on for eleven point
five what time about time I figured I
figured these things would be able to
sell and of course they were so look at
that we made some sick profit off of
that eleven point five million
as you know we already made like a mil
off of that Snapdragon sold oh my gosh
up to twenty six point two five so we're
gonna find some new item well this
didn't go as planned I was looking at
the RS buddy site and it said that these
things bought at about twelve point
seven and solo about twelve point eight
so a little weird I pretty much got
these for twelve point five I do believe
at twelve point five one five so I went
to bed and bought these once I woke up I
tried buying one of these however it
didn't buy I figured these things would
be worth a lot more they're probably
around like 10 to 15 mil right now but
so open I could snipe one anyways try oh
my god I'll try to buy a pair of dragon
boots right now so you guys can see the
price of which it's gonna sell it so 198
for nine Oh which means we'll make about
2k off of all of these which isn't too
bad so I'm going to say this now because
I might forget to mention it in the
video however yesterday I met two merch
zenite shards and I accidentally they
were dropping and I didn't know why it's
because the ring is suffering is he
going to pass in the polls so they
dropped a ton and they drop to about 12
mil but I accidentally bought them at
12.5 so at that point I was like they're
gonna come back up but later that night
I could so I could see that I could sell
them for pretty much why I bought a mat
so I ended up selling them however
whenever they were down like that I
thought about just investing my entire
Bank on my main it back into them
because they dropped two mil and
realistically brings a suffering aren't
that like Opie
so I knew they were gonna go back up and
now look at
a charred price alright as you can see
13.3 mill if I would have invested my
bank into them on my main whenever I had
the chance you I honestly I could have
made somewhere around 25 to 35 mil just
off of one of these merges so all of the
d boots have sold some point three three
melts or at twenty six point three we're
going to try to find a different item
though d boots are a good thing to do on
the side if you have a lot of money if
they're your main item though not that
great went to go play soccer and all the
vc10 bought so I'm gonna do if we're
gonna see what they got a sell for so
after a little while all of the seeds
have sold gonna collect at all and
worked about twenty six point six yeah
around there that's what I figured we'd
be I did a little bit of late night uh
flips I didn't actually find out what
the sell price well it's of heavy
ballistas however I saw that there was
at least 150 K so I figured I'd take
that right so if you guys look in the
PM's that's just me trying to have some
dude scam me I was just I was wondering
what kind of lure he was gonna use but
he didn't even respond so we'll clear
that anyways as you guys may see two
heavy pelisses sold over it not a good
thing um they sold for eleven point five
militant for eleven point seven five so
500k loss in total fool so this will be
a speed a different one so as you can
see we ended up buying a hundred ninety
nine at you seeds for sixteen point six
mill however they do sell for 88 k the
guy price says 85 but right now they're
selling for 88 k insta sells so I figure
I will just kind of flip these it should
be about a 4k profit on each of these if
they do indeed sit well would you look
at that all of my youth saplings have
sold not really for the price I expected
them to however they didn't need sell so
are up to twenty six point nine mil ish
almost well oh look what I just bought
um I've got some snapdragons see it's
161 of them we'll do what we can with
those torso seats all of them have
bought kind of scary and ran are as well
try to take a guess on the price of
those and as you can see you didn't pay
off for me just woke up and all of these
seeds have sold so that's good
not the best merch going on here I mean
I don't want to I don't want to downplay
it at all but some meet somebody to
weaken a it's not terrible I did have to
find the margin so I'm already down 70
to date technically but well as you can
see here the two that I had bought both
of them sold and then I ended up buying
another one and that ended up selling so
we have three in total that we flipped
so far another two bought and sold so
we're gonna be able to buy I believe two
more we can check it out for ourselves
holy [__] what the [__] is this one two
three four yeah two more and would you
look at that all of the happy ballistas
have so had no [__] way we got it to
buy let's go now we're just gonna sell
it on pro merger in the house let's go
I'm back here we go yeah look what I
bought it for twenty four points you
look what I sold it for twenty three
point two they'll flip though the flip
god [__] lost 1 mil on it I'm so
pissed I don't even know what I'm
supposed to do well what would something
that's pretty predictable and not not
not easy to [__] up I guess is the point
well morning time all the damn seeds are
sold so we made a little bit of money
not a ton Farrow scepters haven't bought
which is a little depressing is they
don't they would but I'm gonna try to
get in to do another merch hopefully
some fair acceptors is what I'm gonna
aim to buy I wonder if you guys can hear
the fan anyways this is some [__] so
look at the price for 695 as you can see
I bought and sold one that was the price
of which it was at and all five instable
so I'm guessing someone just dumped them
on me but I'm really not too upset about
it because I think I can still some on
four four seven six five okay well I was
scared however they ended up all selling
so I'm probably gonna try actually I can
only buy two more but I'm just gonna
throw in an offer for two and hopefully
they will buy don't just got back and
four of these the white Bliss's have
sold I'm pretty sure there's a huge
margin on them I know they take a long
time to flip but since I had work and
gonna be going back to work here shortly
I figured it's worth it don't lie did
not expect this merch to work however
if you look here it did nineteen point
six mil from eighteen mil that is insane
shift is over
but uh my boluses for football which is
actually surprising I didn't think that
many of them would buy pretty excited
about that though so now we are going to
sell a month as you can see nineteen
point nine mil again pretty much 20 mil
and I bought them for eighteen point
five so these things are insane I didn't
think they'd be this good and this might
be an item I merged a lot in the future
so as you can see the less of the
militias have bought so we're gonna grab
that one and then three of the ballistas
have sold so we are going to buy back a
little bit more these high light
ballistas they're actually the best
merch bright probably my best like item
merged so far the series so I'm loving
it so I'm about to go to bed as you can
see both of that light ballistas have
sold however one big buys we're gonna
list that one back up probably gonna
offer some light ballistas overnight so
we're about to do that real quick our
profit has been insane today and I'm
excited to look and see what the cash
back because I hear it a little bit just
woke up and the one below says sold and
five of them haven't bought it so we're
just gonna have to check out what price
these things are currently selling out
alright so I checked it out on the RS
buddies site and it says around four
point seven seven mil which means we'll
make about 200k and each one of these
makes a little profit about four or one
mil in total I believe well about to go
to work but two of these have BOTS we're
going to go on and sell five of these
for I believe four six nine eight K I
think that's what we're gonna be able to
sell them for not the profit that we had
yesterday on these however not too bad
in the end okay well I lied so as you
can see I think someone was trying to
check out what the what the margins were
on this so now we're gonna sell that
went on - all right guys how are you
guys doing yeah this uh this account
looks a little different I know right
it's 2 a.m. just finished editing the
video gonna upload
overnight I hope you guys enjoyed so
basically the cash stack that we ended
off with was thirty two point four mil
considering we started with somewhere I
believe around twenty five mil that's
insane for an episode I'm gonna try to
make these more as like a weekly episode
just because I don't want to just crowd
my videos with it and I also like to get
a lot of progress in each video I know a
lot of other merging series are kind of
like day by day and they do a lot of
small merges to fill time I'm not really
about that I want to make as much money
as I can as fast as I can so I'm gonna
do bigger items just cuz that makes more
sense to me even if I can't get the
amount of videos that I want out of it
so if you guys did enjoy feel free to
leave a like if you guys want to see
more of my content you can go ahead and
click on my channel or if you want to
see that newest content you can
subscribe nonetheless hope you guys have
a wonderful day and if you have any ways
of improving my videos or any
suggestions leave them in the comments
down below
hope you guys have a wonderful day and
peace